is it just me or is it getting crazier
out there it's official creepy clowns
are trending the movie Joker has hit the
film festival circuit reviews are coming
in and we're gonna tell you what critics
are saying about it right now on the
ketchup
Joker debuted at the Venice Film
Festival and was given in eight-minute
standing ovation
eight minutes of clapping you guys it
was like the announcement of a new
iPhone at an Apple event the Todd
Phillips directed movie currently sits
at 83% on the tomato meter and comic
book calms Brandon Davis called it
unlike anything before it the movie is
dark thrilling and chilling an insane
masterpiece Anson's Joker is a beloved
DC comic book villain the movie
naturally falls under the label of a
comic book movie really putting my
higher education into practice here but
with comparisons to grittier films like
Dark Knight and Logan not to mention the
obvious inspiration drawn from certified
fresh' Scorsese films like taxi driver
and the king of comedy reviews are
showing it to be way more than just
another comic book movie in fact nerd
reactors John windrow it's definitely a
game-changer for comic book films Indy
wires David Erlich said Joker is
unquestionably the boldest reinvention
of superhero cinema since the Dark
Knight and Jimbo vota of IGN movies
added Joker isn't just an awesome
comic-book movie it's an awesome movie
period and some of the highest praise
for Joker stems from the performance
given by mr. joaquin phoenix which
deadlines Pete Hammond said a so
dazzling risky and original you might as
well start engraving his name on the
Oscar right now especially since it's
not the easiest name to spell I'm
kidding but as far as how Phoenix
compares to past Joker's including Heath
Ledger's similarly Dark oscar-winning
version from 2008 London evening
standards David Sexton said nobody who
sees this new film will ever need any
other version Dan Casey of Nerdist wrote
Joaquin Phoenix is throwing his hat in
the ring for the title of the greatest
Joker's of all time and he is a serious
contender and Marlowe stern to The Daily
Beast added that Joaquin quote earned
his rightful place alongside Heath
Ledger and Jack Nicholson in the
pantheon of all time greatest Jokers
sorry Jared Leto
some critics also brought up the film's
attempts at social commentary with
themes like class warfare and mental
health timeouts Phillip to semblance
said this is a truly nightmarish vision
of late era capitalism arguably the best
social horror film since yet out dam by
Glen Kenny from Roger Ebert calm said as
social commentary Joker's pernicious
garbage BBC's Nicolas Barber said the
film is way too superficial to take
seriously as a study of class conflict
and mental illness and going one step
further is Richard Lawson of Vanity Fair
who said it may be irresponsible
propaganda for the very men at
pathologize 'as you don't listen dear I
gotta kick it over to you guys now
though what do you make of these reviews
and do they make you more or less
excited to see Joker do you think
Joaquin will be your new favorite Joker
and have you ever clap for anything for
eight minutes in your life let us know
all your thoughts and feelings in the
comment section and for more movie news
head on over to Ryan Tomatoes calm as
always thanks for watching to catch up
fine ass Prez and I'll see you guys next
time
[Music]